yes okay it's a bit of a slow week in
terms of movie stuff for me then someone
asked what I thought about the Zac Efron
Ted Bundy movie trailer alright let's
check it out so why should I look all
right and then I read the comments and
holy [ __ ] then I went down the rabbit
hole and I was like holy [ __ ] so Zac
Efron is playing Ted Bundy in a movie
coming out this movie has a trailer and
the trailer admittedly when I saw the
trailer I was like that tones a bit
light-hearted it kind of comes across as
like a heist movie vibe at first it kind
of threw me off if that was all people
had a problem with that would be the
conversation like oh the tongues a
little weird just check it out when the
movie comes out we'll see for sure it's
probably Ted Bundy's portrayal in the
trailer as well as the tone that mixes
into it but the outrage is that they're
glorifying Ted Bundy and his serial
killings of women Ted Bundy as he's
portrayed in the trailer comes across as
a likeable charismatic dude some
tweeters someone some pretty large
followings were like all the wings the
sexualizing Ted Bundy the wings like
that's that's Ted Bundy how do you think
he had the opportunity to kill all those
women you think he was some socially
awkward [ __ ] hanging out in mama
Fratellis basement eating baby Ruths no
I mean the guy acted as his own
representation in his trial like this is
the narcissism we're dealing with here
he was his own lawyer you want a lawyer
who's better than you nope I'll do it
myself
I'm that good I have no doubt he'd
[ __ ] wink at somebody in the
courtroom and if he didn't actually
literally wink at someone in the
courtroom it's a betrayal to illustrate
a point the portrayal to illustrate the
mindset I don't know I said I agree you
want to accurately portray Ted Bundy for
the monster he was and that's what
they're doing there accurately
portraying him as a charming charismatic
[ __ ] whose charm and charisma
allotted him the opportunity to be a
monster
in fact this outrage just makes me look
forward to it more because it's like you
so accurately represented Ted Bundy that
it makes people uncomfortable I think I
get why it makes people uncomfortable
though I feel like Ted Bundy's a monster
unanimously agreed he was a monster
therefore we like seeing monsters how
monsters should be which is monstrous we
like seeing the idealized version of a
monster we want to see Ted Bundy all
like yeah that would make people more
comfortable people are uncomfortable
seeing the normal side of a serial
killer you know the charming sightseeing
the human-sized or glow he's not human
that's not how monsters are supposed to
act fact is if monsters looked and acted
like monsters then they would rarely be
afforded the opportunity to be monstrous
we have ourselves here a spider if you
paint that spider like anything other
than a spider you're doing the victims
of disservice this particular spider was
generally likable you have to show that
it might make some people uncomfortable
but it's a reality now granted the tone
of the trailer threw me off at first I
was like nas a light-hearted tone for
this act it kind of had a Tarantino
movie trailer vibe to it which is also
another interesting conversation because
Quentin Tarantino is doing the movie
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood which is
about the Manson murders so when that
trailer comes out if it has a Tarantino
esque tone to it is gonna get the same
kind of backlash so now I'm interested
to see what happens when Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood comes out but in the
world in the world of all this outrage
culture I just feel like feelings
supersede facts accurately representing
something only matters if it doesn't
offend people and if it offends people
you can't accurately represent something
or someone I don't know just in terms of
being accurate or being loved it rather
be accurate it's a pretty slippery slope
if you fudge history for the sake of
feelings I think it's [ __ ] an
outrage that comes from people not
understanding how Ted Bundy was able to
be what we know is Ted Bundy which is
the serial killer who killed a lot of
women he got it from being this dude he
didn't get it from being this dude I
don't know that's my rant on the subject
not your video through today my thoughts
on the world and stupid [ __ ] in it but
the new Ted Bundy trailer have you seen
it what do you think about it what do
you think of the portrayal of Ted Bundy
and the tone of the trailer in general
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]